今日セカンドチャンネルの動画は姉公園でない亀田家の紹介は何か別に行って来い
カメラてねその youtube をやる上で大事だからねぇ
メインチャンネルだけでもいいと思ったんですけども今回に関してはまぁサーブでも
いいかなと思いました
今回買ってきたのはこちら企業とパーンたいっっにアルファ5100と
いうことでですねミラーレス一眼ですか
なんて言うんですかあの僕が昔までねずっともっと最近持った
もう充電もできないんで今ずっと充電したんですけどもう電通が32%ってくれてる
こちらの nex サイバーってこれメインチャンネルで出そうかな
はいというちょっと何か
こいつを見た瞬間ウルッとしてしまったので
メインですラーメンかなーっ
不思議な気分ですねちょっとね
やばいなる酒できたがあって落ち着いて話しますね
んすみません
もうトスなどから涙もないんだけどこちらの nex 5 r ですね
家浸からないけど
いろんにおいているあったとこれた年前ですね
はもう懐かしいねん
メックスじゃないです nex のツアー
ああああああ
いきなりぐすみませんはいという感じですね年前から今みた動画が2年前の動画なん
ですけどずっとでその youtube はじめたときに
その右側安っぽいビデオ食べられる
土とって
でまぁ見てくださる方が増えてそのそろそろ出してカメラ買おうかなって言って初めて
買ったのなぁ
玄米の一が2013年の1月ですね
五年来のお正月とかね保証夏に買ったのかねお正月にこの ex ファイバれてくれ
なかったんですけども本当にここがベラ日は
当時の巣きれないほどいろんなもうふっと色々覚えでがあります初めて方も一覧の
俯したってです綺麗なにやこれですごい
大切に使っててディズニー母のは9席で心のヒビ入っちゃったりですそのその限界が来
たということでということを思い出していただいてますね本当にねこんなに
youtube というものつづくことになると思わなかったし
のカメラ市内で僕はここまできたと言っても過言ではないくらいね
ここで一緒にあやってきたカメラですイギリスに僕半年間留学一徹の
留学中もこれを持って打ったんですけども俺らを壊せないぞ俺は終わったけど
匠がねぼくの寅ぞ匠んだねイギリスに行って一緒に遊んでた時に
オレが持って
雑貨磨こう手を振り下ろした瞬間にこの壁の2月に当たって
ベンズたに壊れたというあのーなんかしょっぱい覚えてとかもあります
とりあえず前後日だった大雪でしたこの nex サイバーるっていうカメラはそれ
から出前 dx 5 t とか
nex 6て何とかとからね色々出てて自撮りできるようにこっちもいい
いるカメラというそれで買ってすごいてーしょんが当たったどうぞ思い出します
1年前の道がこのすべてはこのカメラで撮って
イギリスへ留学生のハンドしかもこのカメラを2本から勝ちにもっててずっとこいつと
のバトって何かある時も全部このカメラでれるとってきて
廉造をバスケだつって
遅いです反動がも出しても
それもね充電ができなくなるという現象ですねエラーが出て飛ばにつながらない時が
左右しょっちゅうだって今だともうほぼせなきゃなくて充電もできないっていう状態
ですねんもうね色んなものをとりすぎてて
覚えてがありすぎるんですよたと言ってなんか本当にいろんなところが壊れて水を出し
ても終了を出すこと自体がちょっとおかげ的にもったいないんで
今回別のカメラに
変わることになりましたこっちはもうねそうに良いを取り扱われてこっちでね今日の b
のコツですよとりあえずカメラが変わりますアルファの5200
このこのね東映親戚みたいなもんなんでそんなに見た目は変わらないですけど見た目も
レンズも同じなんでそんなに性能的にはこちらが定かじゃないですけどフォーカスとか
体験みなす人はちょっとがないと思うんですけど僕がはどう
が本当にもうこの彼らを張った時かな2年前外から見てる人めちゃくちゃもう愛用して
て歌にカッコつけて写真撮ってそれでこうなんかスライドそうみたいな動画を出してい
たしこれを買ってから6のなんか youtube に対するきもつっていうのが
はるかに切り替わった
だけですこいつがいないと彼は多分 youtube やってなかった黒色と思います
すごい
僕にとっては貴重なものですかそれ本当にボタン限界まで方が来てるんですよ本当にね
色んなことだった
このカメラを使っているときにを得ることもあったし技術も一緒にとして単焦点レン
ズっていう資源における
連打があるんですけどこれベッドをつけ
てねこうなんかすげーずゲットが破砕で見たりネックロールすればよかった
するおどって女恋する20分くらい取ったら熱望するとパルシュ
sd カード内と保存もできないです今日大切な
本ですそしたら人生で一番大事なものかもしれないな
本当な youtube の原点はこのカメラでしょこのためだからもう全てがカーッ
って言ってそう
でございますよこんな感じか綺麗事例ではなやっぱ何か違うんだよなぁ
んをっなんでカメラ2階展望台からもらったわけでもなく自分で買ったカメラなんです
けどってちょっと正しいモデルに進化しますそれからレイクの新しいのと
とっていければいいなと思っておりますまた次回の動画でお会いしましょう
じゃあなぁ
usb